over the mountains of southern china a
smoke plume is the first distant sign of
this disaster
this is where china eastern flight 5735
came down
it looks less a crash site than a total
disintegration of a boeing 737 carrying
132 people there are no signs of
survivors
search and rescue workers recovered only
tiny pieces of debris
locals found bigger parts strewn further
away
the plane took off from the southern
city of kunming heading for guangzhou
two hours flight away
about an hour in cruising through clear
skies it started plummeting to the earth
this should be almost impossible in a
modern aircraft the rapid descent is
actually perplexing in some ways because
even if you have no power an airplane
will glide forward
from that height 15 minutes
so it was obviously not in a stable
flight position
guangzhou airport became the home of a
makeshift information center
we saw distressed relatives gather
my heart is very heavy because i'm a
colleague of yours
i called his relatives right after i
heard the news
because i had to tell them
this is the airport where that china
eastern airlines flight was supposed to
land and this is where relatives have
come seeking information they're behind
that screen trying to find an answer
because right now there isn't a good
answer as to why a plane that was
cruising along in the middle of the
afternoon should suddenly plunge towards
the ground
there is frankly little hope for these
relatives of finding any survivors
instead the search will turn to answers
tom cheshire sky news guangzhou